[Music]
jameis winston doing a great thing amid
the pandemic he set up a national
hotline for anybody who has questions
about symptoms what they may need to do
excellent work by jameis winston was on
fox news yesterday promoting it and he
talked about
the fact that he was supplanted in tampa
bay by tom brady and what winston said
among other things i have tremendous
faith in my lord and one thing about tom
brady is it's understood that he's the
goat for you to get replaced by tom
brady in a city that you love so much i
guess that's kudos to me
um
i'm not sure that it is kudos to jameis
winston
i don't think that it's an honor to be
replaced by anyone as the starting
quarterback uh but look
i feel bad for jameis winston no one has
shown any interest in the guy he's
healthy he had
5109 passing yards last year chris and
it has been crickets
for
three plus weeks for jameis winston i
can't get over it unless his financial
expectations are so high that no one is
even bothering to talk to him until he
realizes that he isn't worth nearly what
he thinks he's worth once he comes to
that conclusion then maybe some of these
other teams will talk to jameis winston
about a contract for 2020. yeah i think
that's very real i mean again i think we
both and i think a lot of people in the
nfl see some great greatness from jameis
winston when they break down his film
and they go wow you know we've talked
about this a lot his good is not just
good it's great you know but also
there's the stigma of some of the things
he's done you know off the field right
that doesn't help him and i do think
he's corrected his life that way and
i've been around jameis he's got an
electric personality he's got juice too
to where when he's in the locker room
you know he loves football and he makes
everybody else energy rise as well the
biggest problem mike it might be the
price tag like you talked about and the
other thing is this you know a lot of
teams don't want a guy like jameis
winston to come in and be their backup
he's just too talented he's going to
make a lot of starter a lot of starters
not look as good or have guys on the
practice field scratching their head
going wait why aren't we playing him he
out duels our starter every day so
that's where it's james i mean a little
scary i think for jameis winston right
now
but why shouldn't he be the starter then
that's what's amazing to me if he's
going to come in and perform better than
the starter why isn't the team saying
this guy should be our starter and i
know for some teams the financial
commitment is too great to pivot to
someone else you're already all in with
someone else and it's going to be
incredibly expensive and there's going
to be a huge cap problem but i agree
with you you know the backup quarterback
most teams are looking for a guy who
comes in knows his role accepts his role
he's there to prepare the veteran or the
starter excuse me he's there to be the
veteran presence he's there to help the
starter he's there to nudge the starter
but he's not there to try to take the
starters job some places want that one
and two who are battling it out like the
bears this year for the most part they
want a number two who understands this
is who i am this is my role i'm only
gonna play if this guy gets injured and
uh
that makes jameis winston not an
attractive option because he's still
going to want to play and he's going to
want to show up and prove that he's the
best guy on the roster
yeah exactly right i mean well said i
mean that that's exactly right you know
and plus yeah there's going to be teams
that are going to be out there that go i
don't know if i trust them to be my
starter yet so that's a little bit of
the issue with winston to me this is the
play right here for jameis winston
you call the san francisco 49ers you
call the pittsburgh steelers you tell
them i will play for the minimum who
gives a damn about the money at this
point you've made money if you want to
resurrect your career your next signing
you got to get do the teddy bridgewater
you got to go to a team where you know
if you get in you can succeed
if i'm my buddy kyle shanahan you know
and he's probably gonna get pissed that
i'm saying this i'm just gonna say it i
don't care i'm calling jameis winston
you know for the way jimmy garoppolo
looked towards the end of the last
season you got a super bowl team and you
got a guy like nick mullins who i'm sure
is fine but i think that's a that's a
risky proposition and that you know the
steelers the same thing it's coming to
the end for big ben and i think a guy
like mike tomlin could really handle a
guy like jameis winston and i think
james winston could bring juice to that
you know organization and certainly play
well if he got in there
i i think you're on to something with
the 49ers and here's why
kyle shanahan wants to take a guy
and and basically turn him into a robot
right and and i don't mean that in a
pejorative sense that's the way his
offense is that's why kirk cousins works
in an offense like that and not in an
offense where okay kirk when it all
falls apart figure out what you're going
to do it has to be very regimented it
has to be very clear and you have to
tell the guy this is what you're going
to do maybe that's what jameis winston
needs to finally break free from those
moments where
he tries to figure it all out on his own
and it ends up being a complete and
total mess if he could just
buy in completely to someone like kyle
shanahan and and maybe this is what
jameis has always been looking for
someone who will tell him exactly what
to do so he doesn't have to improvise so
he doesn't have to figure it out on his
own he's got the skills physically to
pull it off you put him in a system like
that and he agrees with everything kyle
shanahan tells him to do and when it all
falls apart he just throws it away or
hits the deck and doesn't try to make
something out of nothing
that could be the perfect situation for
him
i i agree mike i mean you hit it i think
you said all the right points shanahan's
he's a master at making the game easy
for the quarterback you know won the run
game two jameis winston's made for play
action pass and to your point in what
you're saying mike i mean you know we
watched the 49ers a lot we were there in
person you watch the super bowl there's
a lot of times shanahan only sends out
two or three receivers but because of
his game planning and knowing formation
usage and how to tie in the play action
pass it'll be two receivers and he'll
make it really simple for the
quarterback he'll say like hey just read
this guy and if he goes that way throw
it to this guy and if he goes that way
throw it to that guy i mean that's
really how he makes it and you're right
he wants a guy like that and it would
take some of the freedoms away from
jameis winston and his ad-limbing and
ad-libbing and backyard type style of
you know going through the reeds and
going all over the place i i am with you
man i think it would be a great fit for
the 49ers i hope my buddy kyle
shanahan's listening and maybe takes my
advice
you mentioned the off-field issues you
know they never really stuck to him in
tampa bay as it related to the team's
attitude toward jameis winston the stuff
at florida state it didn't keep the
buccaneers from making him the first
overall pick he had the three-game
suspension a couple of years ago after
the incident with the uber driver the
nfl ultimately imposed that penalty that
never really seemed to diminish him in
the eyes of the team what got him in
trouble with the team was the 30
interceptions and the regression down
the stretch last year but you may have
some teams that take a a different look
at jameis winston based upon those
things that have never really stuck to
him in tampa the way that maybe they
would with other teams
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports